[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Joe Is
With Us in Springfield Hey Joe welcome
to the Ramsey
Show Dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up I've been listening to
you often on last couple years it hasn't
a lot of things haven't soaked in but
the other day you said that nobody
should own a new truck unless they have
a net worth of a million and they're
debt
free well I bought a new one earlier
this year and so my question number one
is should I sell that truck and
downgrade get something a little bit
more economical so that I can pay it
off how much do you
owe uh
43 no 42 and some change so 43 what's
your household
income 220 210 and you don't have any
money no I have uh I have about 40 in
the bank right
now how long youve been making that kind
of
money oh
years you're making good money why do
you not have
any
well my wife kind of lives YOLO I kind
of live like hey we might live to be 500
and it's just it's been 15 years of just
kind of we've sat down and we've put
budgets together and it just it it
doesn't stick on one end and it does on
one and uh I've just kind of learned to
compromise to keep the marriage happy
and uh but the marriage isn't happy man
I can hear it on
you it's frustrating I mean I love her
to death wouldn't trade her for nothing
but it's frustrating well you know when
you have a divided house um you know
like I hate Christmas I hate
it um you know we spend $4,000 every
year in Christmas and it's to people and
friends and and every year we argue
about it and it just gets me where I
just hate Christmas you know because I
know we're just going to blow a bunch of
money and we shouldn't and we don't have
to yeah you know you you move on you
know you can either dwell on it or you
can just move on and and then and then
you borrowed 40,000 on a truck
yeah yes well I I'm a sales guy so I
have to have a truck that's less than
three years old and so many miles I get
paid 850 a month for my truck allowance
whether you have a car payment or
not that's right and that's where I
would rather tuck to 850 and throw it on
the house we're in a great situation on
the house house is worth about six six
and a quarter we're down to about 270 on
it okay um Joe Joe the the truck the
truck needs to be paid off or it needs
to be sold but it's 10% of your
problem okay the problem that's
screaming at me in this conversation is
you make way too much money to be this
broke I agree and you guys have really
got to sit down and address that you're
just you're you're just a quarter no you
haven't you because just not fixed what
do you but what do you do I think you
need if you can't if you and your wife
can't sit down and dream about a future
that you're willing to control
yourselves for cuz you're not
controlling yourselves you're you have
no self-control in your household and if
you the two of you can't find a house a
dream in in high definition that the two
of you can agree to that is worth
working towards together and worth not
spending everything we make to cause it
to happen then you do need to sit down
with a marriage counselor if that's the
case
often High performing High earning folks
sit down and have this conversation as a
math problem honey we make this much
money we got to make a
budget know I have one I have an Excel
sheet I can show you I know you
do here's what I'm telling you there's a
different conversation when you sit down
with your wife and you hold her hands
and you say honey I can't breathe I'm so
scared we make way too much money I'm
working so
hard and I feel like you and I are
fulling pulling further and further and
further apart and I love you too much to
be frustrated at you all the time CU I
know that's hard to live with and I love
you too much for us to pretend that
we're all joyful and happy once a year
at Christmas and we try to throw money
at our friends and
family instead of being a warm safe
place for them to come
land would you build something different
with me that's a different conversation
then honey look at my spreadsheet look
at this if you just would do this then
we could get out of this crap one of
those she's going to go to her defense
and that defense is probably way older
than you and that's probably been there
since she was a little kid and then you
go to your defense cuz she starts
bombing you back and it's different when
you take ownership and say I want my
wife and I want a family that um I want
a unific a unified front here I want a
unified vision of what we're going to do
and I'm scared to death I'm going to
lose you the irony is is that you think
by acquiescing you're creating peace and
you're not that's the irony the fire is
burning in the basement and it is hot
it's coals yeah and because this it's
eating you up and she can feel that on
you and then she goes about solving that
feeling with the way that her body's
been solving those feelings for her
whole life spending spending and trying
to make people feel good about
themselves and showing people how great
she's
doing and that's different than y'all
two building a life together yeah yeah
and if you guys can't sit down work that
through and start to say we need to
develop a new vision for our future a
different plan other than just spinning
our Wheels feeling like a rat in a wheel
I'm scared I can't do this this is
killing me I cannot live in a situation
where I make a quar million dollars a
year and we have nothing that is just
absurd to me my brain can't do it
anymore my mind can't do it my psyche my
spirit can't do it anymore so we've got
to develop a plan for the future that
we're both willing to work towards and I
want to do that with you let's start
fresh FR a reset not we've got to get on
a budget some but will lead you by the
way to a budget and it's not a
spreadsheet budget it's an every dollar
budget but it'll lead you to the two of
you working together to implement the
plan that you have agreed to together
that both of you had a vote in I love
starting those conversations with I'm
sorry I'm sorry I've tried to control
you the way I know to control a problem
I've tried to solve you I've tried to
fix you I'm sorry let me tell you the
truth I'm scared to death and there's a
different there's a different approach
there someone can enter into your space
that way instead of uh having to swing
back at you it's tough hope that works
for you brother and then pay that truck
off in the next 20 minutes um or couple
months and or sell it one of the two
that's um because it's you know you went
and bought a truck while she went and
bought Christmas I think you yeah you
showed her man I think you spent more so
um there you go and the 850 is coming in
whether you have a truck payment or not
so that doesn't justify it